Das ist wirklich ein kurioses Schauspiel im
Doppel-Sternsystem V404 Cygni: In einer Entfernung
von 7800 Lichtjahren scheint hier ein Schwarzes
Loch völlig außer Kontrolle geraten.
Denn anders als es Schwarze Löcher normalerweise
tun, feuert dieses ungewöhnliche Exemplar
seine Materie-Strahlen nicht in dieselbe Richtung.
Stattdessen eiern dies sogenannten “Jets”
laufend hin und her und ändern ihre Richtung.
Clixoom Science & Fiction - abonniert den
Kanal, denn hier gibt es täglich faszinierende
Science-Videos - herzlich willkommen!
Bei den sogenannten “Jets” handelt es
sich um gigantische Materie-Strahlen, die
bei den meisten uns bekannten Schwarzen Löchern
wie Fontänen aus der sogenannten Akkretionsscheibe
heraus schießen.
Dabei handelt es sich um eine Scheibe aus
Gas und Staub, die fast mit Lichtgeschwindigkeit
um das Loch in der Raumzeit rotiert.
So werden heiße Plasmafetzen ins All katapultiert.
Höchstwahrscheinlich bestehen diese Jets
aus Nickel und Eisen und bewegen sich mit
unglaublichen 200.000 Kilometern PRO SEKUNDE
ins All - das entspricht zwei Drittel der
Lichtgeschwindigkeit.
Forschungsteams wissen immer noch nicht ganz
genau, wie diese sogenannten “Jets” entstehen.
Doch höchstwahrscheinlich sorgen Magnetfelder
dafür, dass das Material peitschenähnlich
weggeschleudert wird.
Nach Auswertung der Chandra-Daten ist die
Energie solcher Jets wohl zum einen von der
Masse und zum anderen eben vom Drehmoment
des Schwarzen Lochs abhängig.
Doch diese Materie-Jets des Schwarzen Lochs
im Sternsystem V404 Cygni verhalten sich ganz
anders als in vergleichbaren Systemen.
Das hat jetzt ein australisches Forschungsteam
durch die Analyse in verschiedenen Wellenlängenbereichen
mit einem Verbund aus zehn US-amerikanischen
Teleskopen zeigen.
Auch der Röntgensatellit „Integral“ der
europäischen Raumfahrtagentur ESA trug einen
Teil dazu bei, denn so konnten die Experten
und Expertinnen bis zum inneren Rand der Akkretionsscheibe
vordringen.
Fest steht: Das Schwarze Loch in diesem Doppelsternsystem
saugt Materie von seinem Begleitstern ab.
Diese sammelt sich dann auf der etwa zehn
Millionen Kilometer breiten Akkretionsscheibe
und strudelt dann in die Schwerkraftfalle.
Doch anders als es sonst bei Schwarzen Löchern
üblich ist, schlingern die Materiejets wild
hin und her.
Das Ganze erinnert ein wenig an eine wildgewordene
Schlange oder aber an einen Gartenschlauch,
der außer Kontrolle geraten ist.
Laut der Fachleute ändert der Jet seine Richtung
in weniger als einer Stunde.
Zur Dynamik des Schwarzen Lochs und der rotierenden
Scheibe sagt James Miller Jones von der ESA:
“Wir glauben, dass die Materiescheibe und
das Schwarze Loch unterschiedlich ausgerichtet
sind.
Das scheint den inneren Bereich der Scheibe
taumeln zu lassen wie einen langsamer werdenden
Kreisel”.
Eine wirklich außergewöhnliche Entdeckung
in 7800 Lichtjahren Entfernung.
Bekannt ist dieses Schwarze Loch, das die
Materie eines Nachbar-Sterns verschlingt,
bereits seit 1989.
Es wird als “stellares” Schwarzes Loch
bezeichnet und hat etwa die neunfache Masse
unserer Sonne.
Viel kleiner also als das supermassereiche
Schwarze Loch “Sagittarius A*” im Zentrum
unserer Milchstraße, das Schätzungen zufolge
4,3 Millionen Mal so schwer ist wie unser
Sonne.
Solche stellaren Schwarzen Löcher wie das
jetzt beobachtete im Sternsystem V404 Cygni
kommen millionenfach in unserer Milchstraße
vor.
Doch warum verhalten sich diese Jets so anders
und entweichen eben nicht wie gewöhnlich
senkrecht zur Scheibe?!
Ursache für all das ist laut Ansicht der
Experten wohl die Supernova, aus der das Schwarze
Loch hervorgegangen war.
Diese könnte dem Schwarzen Loch einen Stoß
versetzt haben und es so zum Taumeln gebracht
haben.
Seine Achse schwankt durch den Raum - vergleichbar
mit einem Kreisel.
Das führt dazu, dass auch der Jet seine Richtung.
verändert.
Dem Astronomen-Team zufolge könnte dies auch
bei anderen Schwarzen Löchern der Fall sein.
Bereits bekannt ist ein weiteres Schwarzes
Loch mit einem rotierenden Jet, der allerdings
sechs Monate für einen Umlauf braucht und
nicht in weniger als einer Stunde.
Verrückt.
Was wäre, wenn ein massives Schwarzes Loche
neben der Erde auftauchen würde?
Panik?
Oder was?
Astro Comics TV klärt es.
Hier Draufklicken, anschauen und Atsrocomics
TV abonnieren.
Bis dann, bleibt dran!